well Tom I didn't know this but juliard
you went to juliard just like Viola
Davis who by the way is so scary in this
movie like that that is like how she
said the word dull I almost peed my
pants yeah I was like don't piss her off
um anyway but I didn't know that you
both went I KN I knew she went there but
I didn't know you did as well that's
amazing did we weren't in the same class
obviously different Generations but I
didn't know you both went there I just
thought that was kind of a cool thing
that's an amazing thing that you you did
in your life that you both have in
common yeah I mean it's the reason I
ended up in New York which is I'm very
grateful for um but it's kind of how we
bonded on set was like talking about you
know our shared stories and weirdly
found out that we have like some of the
same teachers years apart that have
stayed there I was going to ask yeah one
of our movement coaches in school was
the same teacher so he' just been there
his entire existence I guess wow that's
really cool awesome um did you ever
actually get to meet Jennifer Lawrence
anybody here for I did I think I'm the
only one I did um I we were at the the
Paris fashion week for the Dior show a
couple only a couple weeks ago yeah and
um and I didn't want to be weird and I
was just kind of psyching myself up to
talk to her um and she was so
unbelievably kind and in that clip she's
actually saying let's do another photo
where I'm strangling you saying you'll
never take my part
and and that is exactly what I wanted
from her she I love that about her she
seems like the same off screen and on
screen it's amazing that's the cool
thing like working with there's so many
people in this movie too that like Viola
like that that's just amazing to be able
to work with too do you do you get
nervous in scenes with people like that
yeah I mean especially when you see
Viola's costume when she comes in with
that fake ey she scared everything it's
kind of terrifying but then she she
breaks for lunch and she's the funniest
person in the world we were just with
her this morning she's like so funny she
like immediately cuts through any
intimidation she's great I love that
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home